[Music]
one thing I'd like to change about
myself I need to change a lot of things
so you're asking me to narrow it down to
one probably where I live I would love
to just go live somewhere I mean I love
it here no we're spoiled here but I
would love to go check out any places go
to Europe something check it out I could
change one thing about myself I would
try and be more content with each day
rather than
finding fault with the current day I
would say probably my gender even though
I'm not transgender I'm a queer woman
and I'm consistently tired of feeling
the extension of men particularly
straight men sexuality oppressing me
often times they wonder what it would be
like to be a man and although I do enjoy
being a woman as well it has a lot to do
with the fact that it's dodging
objectivity and existing as a person and
not just some form of pleasure so that's
probably one thing I would change you
brought me on a deeper and super
personal level probably my confident
it's hard to be confident well like
youlike but it's also
confidence you know
not to be so hard on myself baby the one
thing I would change about myself
maybe it's my ability to give a better I
guess give a better vanish money a lot
better assertiveness yeah my anger do
not be so passive-aggressive
[Music]
I would change the fact that I don't
know the right answer to questions
immediately probably my stubbornness the
fact that that I don't know how to ride
a bike I guess that would be a good
option my hide I wish I was this much
taller but I'm okay I need a job my
brain find a way we make more money be
richer that's a hard one I actually
really like myself I think if I could
change one thing though I think I would
try to well one thing I'm working on is
patient so I think if I could change one
thing about myself it would be it'll be
more
maybe not getting so frustrated in the
San Diego traffic as of lately
to be able to see things in like more of
a positive light and making a play and
other time I think of like the naked
side of the situation and I feel like it
like hurts me and like it's me and a lot
of things and I really tried to stay
positive but it's like super hard so I
think if I had to change like one thing
to be able to like like see the glass
like half-full
just always trying to be on time just
always try to be punctual and always be
on time and kind of caring about people
wanting me to be punctual and would
probably not take like ten shits a day I
wish I was smarter
well it's something that I'm already
actively working on changing which is to
trust God and life more probably not be
like one of those people who waits to do
something to the last
definitely has affected my life and more
negative ways and positive even though
it's been like nice to relax and not do
the things but definitely that probably
how likes I am I'm very shy so like I
want to be more outgoing with you think
being able to meet more new people they
talk to them instead of two sites they
buy it think maybe a little bit of my
personality I can be a bit demanding
sometimes and impatience and I would
like to yeah change that if that's
possible
that would be possible
good question
I'd say I'd get myself out of my comfort
zone a lot more thanks man's if you like
you're doing that right now
I am you to be kinder I think we've all
changed that about I thrive
[Music]
[Music]